nous voici arrivé à la Dominique pressé
de découvrir l'état de cette île réputée
pour ses centaines de rivières et ses
1000 forêts luxuriantes il nous tarde de
voir sa nouvelle topographie et surtout
de prendre son pou économique après les
dommages causés par le terrible cyclone
Maria survenu le 17 septembre 2017 la
surprise risque d'être saisissante quand
on sait 90 % des habitations
infrastructure publique et privée avait
été soufflé par les violents assaut
d'riica en 2016 puis Maria un an plus
tard la redécouverte du pays est
stupéfiante la ville est de nouveau
animée les toitures sont refaites les
travaux de reconstruction évoluent à la
vitesse grandv et même le marché
touristique a subi un lifting visible au
premier coup d'œil à ROSO la capitale la
rue principale qui longe l'embarcadaire
accueillant les bateaux venant de toutes
parts égorger touristes il y a encore
quelques mois ils étaient déroutés vers
la Guadeloupe et la Martinique pour
cause de pays ravagés les visiteurs
arpentent les différents étales ils
partent rarement les mains vides ici le
moindre sou est une manne à ne pas
négliger le signal économique est fort
les affaires semblent
reprendre les autochtones exploit toutes
les possibilités de gagner quelques
dollars les touristes allemands pour la
plupart sont sous le charme de
l mais connaissent-il les déboirs
climatiques successifs qui ont fragilisé
la
Dominique paradisiaque nousous baladons
dans la ville nous marchons sur la plage
super les gens sont gentils
fantastique il y a eu le cyclone Maria
il y a 2 ans je pense que c'était
terrible pour
eux V là mais oui n
comm
bien satisfait c'est qui ça satisfait on
s 150 satisfait
150ci ouis ouais Satis
oui plus Satis
satisp tous les secteurs reprennent vie
les professionnels n'hésitent pas à
reconnaître l'efficacité du
gouvernement moi j'étais ici pour Maria
et pour vous arrê je suis vraiment
surprise le façon que le pays a rebondit
si vite ça c'est les choses revient très
très vite il un pe beaucoup plus de
petit business et c'est à cause du
gouvernement qui a pu aider beaucoup de
personnes qui ont perdu leur travail à
avoir l'autre propre à être indépendant
comme ça ces gens-là ils ont leur propre
business et ça marche très bien pour eux
là
maintenant ne pas lâcher prise ne pas
sombrer dans la cistana c'est la
première devise de ce peuple fédéré face
à la dévine alors l'idée pour le
gouvernement dominicain c'est de faire
en sorte que tout le monde s'implique
dans la marche vers le rééquilibre
économique et social de la
Dominique pour remonter les entreprises
les pouvoirs publics apporte des moyens
financiers mais contribu aussi à la
logistique nous n'avons pas d'autre
choix que de reconstruire quand vouszme
chantier comme ça vous devez vous aider
vous-même donc je voudrais vraiment
remercier la Martinique la Guadeloupe et
tout le reste de la
Caraïbe le cyclone est passé en
septembre
2017 et en janvier 2018 nous avons vu le
premier bateau de coisier revenir nous
étions prêts pour les
affaires et la reconstruction d'un pays
quasi anéanti requiert l'exploration de
stratégie efficace et fiable l'idée
intéressante c'est de promouvoir la
culture dominicaise à travers des
événements fess
tout de suite après le cyclone Maria
nous avons organisé notre premier
carnaval il n'était pas grand mais on
l'a fait c'était un carnaval spontané
les groupes se sont improvisé et tout le
monde
s'amusait nous comptions sur ce carnaval
qui était l'expression même de notre
culture nous en avons profité pour
inciter les gens à venir à la Dominique
et les inviter à coopérer aux ambitions
économiques
[Musique]
le carnaval jusque là vécu de façon
intimiste par les Dominicains devient
aujourd'hui un outil touristique
majeur les gros papierers qu'ils
appellent les bandes s'inscrivent par
dizaine au parade qui démar généralement
le deè samedi de
l'année certains groupes sont organisés
et d'autres intègrent les parades sans
aucune formalité
un événement qui intervient pendant la
période
touristique une animation qui permet de
faire connaître un des aspects de la
culture dominiicaise aux étrangers une
incitation à choisir la destination Dom
minque un plus pour enflouer les caisses
de l'État grâce au taxes perçu mais pas
forcément bénéfique pour les
[Musique]
commerçants
maiseloupe
[Rires]
[Musique]
pas de thme imposé pour les parades mais
Didier l'Office de Tourisme de la
Dominique s'efforce d'inciter les
adeptes du carnaval à mettre la
tradition en avant ici il fabriqu des
costumes de carnaval qu'ils appellent
des boisbois des masses c'est une petite
association formée d'une dizaine de
jeunes elle ne perçoit pas d'aide
financière du gouvernement elle a
seulement l'autorisation d'utiliser
gracieusement un coin du stade en guise
d'atelier
nous travaillons tous je suis mécanicien
vous avez des professeurs des gens de
différents secteurs
professionnel carnaval nous sommes
ensemble juste pour faire les
costumes pas vraiment d'atelier nous
utilisons le stade mois dans l'année
pour le carnaval et ensuite n
occupations un personnage de bande
dessiné
c'est un film la bande dessinée
Elana et c'est le costume du concours de
reine il y a du
papier de la
peinture nous avons fait toute la
peinture à la
main et vous voyez dans le kit de base
il y a toutes sortes de matériaux de
recyclage les matériaux sont
généralement des éléments naturels
collectés parci par là pour tissu ou
autre matériaux nobl les clients sont
facturés les sommes réclamées sont
maudiques comparativement au tarifs
pratiqués par les couturier
professionnel ce costume par exemple a
été confectionné pour une candidate au
concours de reine du carnaval c'était
l'année dernière elle a
gagné ce costume était dans les rues
lors de la première parade donc l'année
dernière les gens on pu voir ce qu'on
fabrique en matière de production
locale les bûchettes de coco
le Pier et toutes les autres
matières et ça représente quoi la nature
oui c'est ce que nous faisons en
production
locale pour toutes les associations qui
uvrent pour la culture et notamment le
carnaval l'état dominicain ne prévoit
pas de budget pour les subventions les
adhérents sont tous
volontaires l'une des attractions
plébisité lors des parades la voici en
répétition jardin botanique r les
boisbois appelés en France les
échasses le président
de n'a que 23 ans il se bat pour que
vive le carnaval dominiic depuis sa plus
tendre
enfance nous avons ce groupe depuis
1996 nous l'avons fondé pour participer
au PARAD du carnaval nous sommes
indépendants nos activités tourne autour
des attractions c'est un groupe
d'attraction nous avons actuellement 40
membres des membres
actifs on vous donne des
subventions nous obtenons des aides pour
les fabrication des costumes ou de
l'aide de domelec la compagnie
d'électricité nous avons aussi digicell
qui sponsorise pour les cadeaux nous
faisons des activités tout au long de
l'année le gouvernement ne vous aide pas
le gouvernement ne sponsorise pas
actuellement parce que nous n'avons pas
encore besoin de lui nous tentons de
faire de notre mieux pour faire ce que
nous avons à faire
nous-mêmes les membres de cette
association sont très jeunes
l'apprentissage commence dès l'âge de 5
ans des
bébés tu arrives à marché avec
ça
ou fait je dois B
lancer seul les plus courageux et les
plus habiles restent jusqu'à leur
majorité tenir en équilibre pendant des
heures ce n'est pas donné à tout le
monde mais le gouvernement dominiquet
possède aussi des outils de
développement pour la promotion de la
culture sit tué à kenfield le centre
culturel public est un site historique
costume créol déguisements typiqu des
parades dominicaises sont exposés dans
une salle entièrement dédié à l'histoire
du carnaval même les instruments de
musique utilisés pendant des décennies
sont visibles dans la salle
d'expo une dizaine d'agents sont
employés dans cette institution ils sont
en mode veille la tradition doit vivre
et demeurer un élément culturel fort
qu'il convient de
préserver plusurs aspect carnaval
plusieurs aspect hitage Dominique adon
festival
avant c'est des j
dans
mais
carnavalér
j
carav alors costum là c'est qui ça
quiostciostum
[Musique]
Afrique papier
tout qui ça
fait encore un argument touristique pour
attirer les visiteurs
étrangers J passage au Centre Culturel
nous rencontrons par hasard deux élus du
ministère du Tourisme ils sont en
repérage ils recensent les éléments
culturels à
promouvoir même si le ministère de la
Culture et du Tourisme et notre
partenaire après le cyclone nous avions
vraiment besoin de réhabiliter nos sites
réhabiliter nos bâtiments et faire
savoir que le marché Dominic était
opérationnel pour les affaires
le gouvernement a investi plus de 6
millions de dollars pour la
réhabilitation des
sites pour nous le carnaval et tous les
festivals font partie de nos campagnes
de marketing pour inciter les gens à
venir à la Dominique visiter la
Dominique et pas seulement les
sites pour la promotion des événements
culturels les Dominicains ne lésignent
pas sur les moyens les campagnes
débutent très tôt le festival Jazz
créole qui se déroule au mois de mai
fait l'objet de conférence de presse dès
le mois de janvier ce soir un mini
concert est organisé à l'Alliance
Française les artistes choisis pour
figurer sur la bande annonce sont la
chanteuse anglaise John L et la non
moins célèbre chanteuse dominicaise
Michel
[Musique]
Anderson la résonance du Jazz crol
Festival
2019 sur le
[Musique]
renommé carnaval Jazz crol Festival
Musique crol festival tous ces
événements se préparent à
Didier
Dom en somme Tourisme du Pays l'équipe
composée d'une trentaine de personnes
gère en même temps la communication de
toutes les actions culturelles de
l'année ell définissent ensemble les
différentes stratégies qui permettront
d'attirer à la fois les autochtones et
les visiteurs étrangers tout cela avec
un portefeuille pas très garni émanant
du ministère du
Tourisme n festival pass céit plus ça
c'est pour
gouver
pour pas fa ça à côté ça plus fa
vem plus l' dans
fesal permission pour carnaval ah mais
c'est parce que savent que ça important
aussi carnaval ça combi pour fa
ça
pour
assez pour en carnaval comme ça ça
peut-être qu' fait n 2000 dollars ça pas
dit 2000 dollar pour
mais en matière d'événement pour attirer
les touristes un nouveau phénomène
commence à voir le jour en Dominique les
soirées de carnaval privé ce jeune homme
est le propriétaire d'astafan un des
plus anciens hypermarchés de lîle avec
une petite équipe il développe les
soirées ma par elle se déroule pendant
les jours gras un concept all inclusive
qu'il propose via Internet avec un seul
billet les internautes du monde entier
peuvent participer à toutes les
festivités de carnaval ils peuvent aussi
manger et boire un package comprenant
notamment le costume leurit remis dès
leur
arrivée j'ai besoin de deux
tickets de tickets pour le par et
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici
c'est le deuxème lieu où l'on peut se
procurer des tickets pour le More tu
peux réserver ton ticket en ligne sur
internet mais si tu es en Dominique tu
n'es pas obligé d'aller sur internet tu
peux venir le payer
cash ça c'est le reçu il y a ton nom le
nom de
l'événement tu as la date l'heure le
lieu
d'achat le jour du jour tu viens au
guichet tu passes une
porte tu donnes le reçu il trve ton nom
il te donne package et tout est dans le
sac depuis la création de ce concept
Emad ne vend plus de costume de carnaval
dans son magasin en revanche le rayon
tissu est toujours garni des matières
les plus utilisé pour la confection des
déguisements nous avons beaucoup de gens
qui achètent ici pour le
carnaval ils viennente la journée il
prépare les de jours de carnaval lundi
et mardi gras il recherche des sens des
échass ils recherchent toutes sortes de
choses pour leur
déguisement depuis le passage du cyclone
Maria le thème c'est la tradition la
culture les meilleurs clients sont
souvent les établissements
scolaires en ce moment je fabrique des
costumes pour un groupe d'écoliers donc
j'ai besoin de tissu et de matériaux
pour les élèves un groupe d'écoliers
avec des enfants donc oui ils ont entre
4 et 11 ans pour le carnaval je ne sais
pas si ce sera lundi ou mardi mais ils
seront dans les rues avec leur
costumes des élèves qui très jeunes ont
pour certains le devoir de porter la
culture dominicaise très loin cette
jeune collégienne se prépare à affronter
une vingtaine d'autres filles de son âge
se présentant comme elle un concours de
beauté qui a lieu chaque
année compétition se déroule en période
de carnaval et l'heureux élu à la lourde
charge de représenter la Dominique dans
tous les concours de beauté du
monde son coach est un transigeent elle
doit être parfaite elle est l'une des
ambassadrices potentielles du pays
[Musique]
comp il faut pays pour représenter Dom
ch pour
gortunité pour faire d'ut aussi mais le
plus grand espoir de la Dominique se
situe au nord de l'île nous voici en
route pour port smouth la ville qui
devait être la capitale de lîle avec un
peu moins de 3000 habitants c'est un
véritable avre de paix cette plage par
exemple est de plus en plus fréquenté
par les riches plaisantiers étrangers la
demande est grandissante l'offre doit
les activités locales commencent donc à
se
développer la période où l'on gagne le
plus d'argent c'est celle de la saison
touristique oui
mtenant vous pas le Jaz crole c'est
seulement pour 2 jours quand c'est la
période touristique pendant 6 mois nous
gagnons davantage d'argent les touristes
viennent du monde
entier des restaurants ouverts en sur la
plage il y en a PE mais ils uvrent dans
la tradition locale et fait des
paysements garantis pour les
touristes mais les projets les plus
sérieux en matière de tourisme et de
développement économique se bâtissent
tout autour de pormou trois hôtels 5
étoiles se dresse à la vitesse de
l'éclair la clientèle est donc ciblée
difficile d'imaginer ce que prévoit le
gouvernement pour accueillir les
visiteurs de classe
inférieure
en Dominique nous sommes d'accord pour
dire que nous voulons la qualité pas la
quantité nous suiv une stratégie nous
n'avons pas besoin de plage et de s
surpupes stratégies sont incl dans le
programme d'investissement proposé par
le gouvernement vous pouvez aussi bien
trouver une
t Ilir que hôs que vous avez vu à son
des programmes qui sont bas sur notre
chip hôs
avant sont programmes qui sont bien
étudié donc il y avait pas de raison
qu'on les arrête donc ces projets
continuent et dans le courant de cette
année 2019 et 2000 2020 on aura donc
trois hôtels 5 étoiles dans la zone de
portsmth qui vont être là ouvert à tout
le monde et et notamment aux personnes
de Martinique et de Guadeloupe le
gouvernement dominicain reconnaît que
les visiteurs les plus fréquents
viennent de Martinique et de Guadeloupe
et pour cela il n'y a pas de saison ils
viennent tout l'année la coopération
avec ces deux îles françaises doit
perdurer lors d'épisodes climatiqu
catastrophique ce sont les premiers
secours les événements culturels comme
le carnaval doivent donc devenir une
raison plus agréable d'approcher la
Dominique les intis français pour nous
c'est c'est vraiment des des des
personnes que nous voulons cibler pour
faire venir à la Dominique on sait que
le carnaval est se fait à la même
période en Martinique et en Guadeloupe
maintenant on a envie de faire en sorte
à ce que les personnes de Martinique et
Guadeloupe vivent notre carnaval et il
faut qu'on les fasse venir et et et on
va faire tout ce qu'il nous faut pour
qu'on puisse faire en sorte à ce que on
partage cette expérience avec vous en
attendant la construction de ces hôtels
et la reconstruction de l'aéroport
international de Melleville pour le
retour à l'équilibre les dominiicis
doivent s'appuyer fortement sur le
tourisme de croisière chaque visiteur
dépense en moyenne une dizaine de
dollars US pas suffisant pour parler de
vraie reprise économique mais assez pour
dire que la sortie de la survie pour
revenir à la vie va crchando les
commerçants devrai pouvoir encaisser de
quoi voir plus loin grâce aux touristes
allemands qui selon eux sont les plus
généreux une saison touristique qui
finit en novembre en période du festival
de musique
[Musique]
créole en attendant depuis la mi-janvier
les rues de la capitale sont prises
d'assaut par les groupes de carnaval les
parades vont bon train jusqu'au Mardi
Gras ils prneront leur culture de
carnaval la résilience dont les
dominiicains font preuve depuis quelques
années semble porter ses
fruits